wie geht es weiter mit einem antrag der
unionsfraktion zu es geht um die
bekämpfung der preissteigerung und du
musst kurz zu machen heute am frühen
abend der ist ja im bundestag die and
das entlastungs paket der
bundesregierung für bürgerinnen und
bürger in der ersten beratung und das
geht aber der unionsfraktion nicht weit
genug und deswegen hat ja eine ganze
reihe von vorschlägen
zusammengefasst auch sehr
unterschiedlichen gebieten ist so ein
bisschen hat man vorübergehend den
eindruck eines sammelsuriums aber all
dieses bündel an maßnahmen hatte die
union zusammengetragen um bürgerinnen
und bürger zu entlasten wir schauen mal
eben in den plenarsaal ist noch eine
gewisse unruhe weil hier doch die
fachpolitiker jetzt ein wenig
durchwechseln und wir schauen wer der
erste redner sein wird michael meister
aus der unionsfraktion ist auf dem weg
zum pult und stellt den antrag der
unionsfraktion vor meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren heute steht die
situation der menschen in unserem land
auf antrag der cdu csu fraktion hier auf
der tagesordnung
die preise schießen seit monaten in den
himmel
das war lange bevor der angriffskrieg
von russland auf die ukraine begonnen
hat aber die auswirkungen dieses krieges
beschleunigen die entwicklung
die menschen erleben dass tagtäglich an
der supermarktkasse wie die
lebensmittelpreise nach oben gehen die
menschen erleben dass an der tankstelle
bei den energiepreisen und da will ich
den hinweis geben dass viele
lieferverträge haben bei strom bei gas
mit festpreisen die irgendwann enden
werden das heißt wir sehen aktuell noch
nicht die volle wirkung der inflation
ein teil der wirkung wird erst in den
kommenden monaten auf die menschen
zukommen und das ist unabänderlich dass
es geschieht
und viele menschen in unserem land haben
vorgesorgt für die zukunft haben eine
altersversorgung aufgebaut außerhalb der
gesetzlichen rente und müssen jetzt
erleben dass über inflation das was sie
an vorsorge für das alter aufgebaut
haben entwertet wird
und wenn wir die teuerungsraten sehen
aktuell von 7,4 prozent
dann ist es etwas was über mein herr
erfahrungshorizont und ich bin jetzt 28
jahre mitglied dieses parlaments
hinausgeht seit 40 jahren haben wir
keine solche entwicklung in deutschland
erlebt und deshalb müssen wir dringend
dagegen arbeitet meine damen und herren
nun ist es richtig dass zunächst mal die
verantwortung für die geldpolitik bei
der zentralbank liegt die unionsfraktion
respektiert die unabhängigkeit der
zentralbank
und die zentralbank hat ein mandat und
wir erwarten dass die zentralbank dieses
mandat in dieser außergewöhnlichen
situation entschlossen kraftvoll und
zeichner war nicht meine damen und
herren
es gibt aber jenseits der geldpolitik
der zentralbank auch eine verantwortung
der finanz und wirtschaftspolitik und
über die finanz und wirtschaftspolitik
in diesem land müssen wir hier
diskutieren und stellt die
bundesregierung in der verantwortung
dort die notwendigen entscheidungen zu
treffen und bei der finanz und
wirtschaftspolitik gibt es an diesem
thema zwei dimensionen wie eine frage
ist was können wir tun um die ursachen
der inflation zu bekämpfen und die
zweite frage ist was können wir tun per
brandner sie haben auch gelegenheit
bringen sich sachkundigen dabei uns
keine wilden zwischenrufe zu machen
neben der dimensionen ursache gibt es
die frage auswirkungen und ich glaube
wir stehen die verantwortung dass wir
uns um beide themen kümmern wir müssen
die ursachen bekämpfen damit es nicht
zur dauer wirkung wird und wir müssen
die auswirkungen auf die menschen
bekämpfen
und jetzt hat nicht gestern sehr gefreut
herr bundesfinanzminister lindner hat er
sie ein strategiepapier zur angebots
orientierten politik vorgelegt haben ich
glaube dass solche gedanken einen
beitrag leisten können um gegen das
thema ursache etwas zu tun ich erwarte
allerdings dass es nicht ein papier des
bundesfinanzministers bleibt sondern
dass die bundesregierung sich dieses
papier umgehend zu eigen macht und dann
nicht nur ein papier auf dem tisch liegt
sondern dass die maßnahmen die zu
anderen uns orientierten politik dort
genannt sind auch zeitnah umgesetzt
werden und da will ich mal ein beispiel
nennen wir hätten heute die chance
gehabt
handelsschranken abzubauen indem bei
über zeta enthalten sie haben es leider
von der tagesordnung genommen wir können
nicht entscheiden das während beitrag
zur angebots orientierten politik nicht
den einigen monaten sondern es könnte
heute geschehen hier in diesem haus wir
stehen vor der frage wo kommen wir aus
einer temporären installation eine
dauerhafte entwicklung nämlich über die
frage kommen wir in eine
lohn-preis-spirale rein bisher haben wir
sie nicht und ich erwarte jetzt von der
bundesregierung dass sie alles in ihrer
kraft stehende tun um gegen eine solche
lohn-preis-spirale anzukämpfen denn es
kann nicht sein dass wir dauerhaft uns
in eine inflations situation hinein
begeben dort klingt eine verantwortung
handeln sie jetzt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
gibt eine reihe von themen ich will mal
heraus greifen das thema staatsschulden
die bundesregierung beabsichtigt im
laufe diesen jahres ermächtigungen
einzuholen für 300 milliarden euro neue
kredite darüber werden wir an anderer
stelle diskutieren aber ich erwarte dass
wir die schuldenbremse am ersten januar
2000 23 meter einhalten das ist ein
signal an den markt das ist ein signal
an andere länder in europa und es gibt
der zentralbank den spielraum den sie
dringend braucht um das vernünftige
geldpolitik zu machen und zum abschluss
weil wir die zeit frau präsidentin etwas
davon läuft geht noch viel zu sagen
wir haben auch in europa den stabilitäts
und wachstumspakt außer kraft gesetzt
auch das meer dringend notwendig dass am
ersten januar der wieder in kraft tritt
und ich erwarte dass man nicht sich in
der formulierung versteckt als
bundesregierung wir warten die prüfung
der kommission nein hier ist ein klares
signal an den markt und an unsere
anderen mitgliedstaaten im euroraum zu
erwarten vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit wir werden die diskussion
an anderer stelle weiter
michael meister für die unionsfraktion
und zu deren antrag wird kämpfen der
inflation eine ganze reihe von
vorschlägen hat die union in diesem
antrag gemacht die gegenrede dazu von
verena hubert der stellvertretenden
vorsitzenden der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wo soll ich
anfangen
sie schreiben und sprechen von angst ihr
antrag der art mit angst wir leben in
einer zeit von angst du kannst vor krieg
angst vor inflation angst vor
wohlstandsverlust und sie sagen was
können wir denn tun haben sie nicht
mitbekommen was wir tun nämlich eine
ganze menge also ich meine
entschuldigung
ich habe extra noch mal alles ausgebucht
und mitgebracht und ist doch schön dass
sie das hier mal ausgerufen und wir
jetzt wirklich auch dann noch mal stück
für stück durchgehen können
entlastungspaket ja wir lernen alle noch
was hier miteinander
123 und auch vieles was gar nicht in
paketen gedacht wird wir haben wirklich
jede menge auf den weg gebracht wir
werden zum ersten juli die eg eeg-umlage
abschaffen heizkostenzuschuss gibt es
für die es gibt sofort sie von der fdp
da gibt es überhaupt keine produktiven
zuschlägen eder hören sie jetzt auch mal
wozu also nein
wir haben ein entlastungspaket auf den
weg gebracht wir haben ein zweites auf
den weg gebracht wo wir wirklich auch
verkehrsbund
übergreifend von der tankstelle bis zum
pnv heute ist die lesung auch für das
man euro ticket wir gucken eben nicht
die eine maßnahme die gerade das leben
teurer macht sondern inflation ist ja
ein warenkorb da sind ja mal ein paar
dinge drin und da gibt es jetzt auch
nicht die eine lösung und das eine was
wir tun können und in diesen zeiten ist
doch auch mal ein kühler kopf vielleicht
ganz angemessen wir können immer
natürlich abdämpfen stoß federn aber wir
müssen ja auch mal an die wurzel von
problemen
[Applaus]
weiter jetzt konzentrieren wir uns noch
einmal kurz auf die debatte ich wusste
gar nicht dass sie hier auch somit aktiv
sind wir haben entlastungs paket auf den
weg gebracht wir wollen aber an die
wurzel des problems die wurzel des
problems bedeutet natürlich auch zu
schauen warum märkte preise obwohl sich
rohölpreise gar nicht steigern an der
tankstelle weitergeben dass wir schnell
weg kommen von eben den fossilen
energieträgern die knapp sind und
neben diesen entlastungs paketen die
primär auf die bürgerinnen und bürger
einzahlen wir haben da natürlich jetzt
auch was für die unternehmen auf den weg
gebracht und das erste die kfw kredite
sind am montag gestartet die
bürgschaften letzte woche wir haben
neben den krediten aber auch die
möglichkeiten des temporary kreis des
frameworks genutzt also zuschüsse weil
viele unternehmen eben auch nicht mehr
in der lage sind noch mehr kredite und
noch mehr kredite aufzunehmen die
langfristigkeit
[Applaus]
langfristig agieren bedeutet aber auch
und der kollege schrodi aus dem
finanzbereich wird er gleich noch mal
drauf eingehen wir haben auch
steuerentlastungen die rückwirkend
greifen werden ab dem ersten januar in
dem wir freibeträge erhöhen wir werden
auch ans bafa eingehen denn hier am
antrag schreiben sie auf was es mit den
studierenden bafög heute erste novelle
endlich mal wieder nötig dass da auch
was vorangeht für die studierenden in
diesem land
und die pakete sind stoßdämpfer wir
haben
wir haben die inflation hat verschiedene
facetten die inflation kommt aus der
energie aber sie kommt auch aus den
verschiedenen anderen warengruppen die
jetzt eben auch steigen und ich will
jetzt hier mal noch zum abschluss einen
satz sagen hier antrag liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen aus der union das ist ein
gemischtwarenladen an ich wünsche mir
mal was und wenn ich jetzt nein sage wir
müssen mehr entlasten wir müssen auch
die steuer noch mehr senken aber bitte
halten wir doch mal die schuldenbremse
ein das ist doch widersprüchlich par
excellence und deswegen die ampel liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben gut
gute dinge auf den weg gebracht heute
wird in 15 stunden viel beraten und
deswegen lehnen wir aber gleich diesen
antrag und ich freue mich noch über
gewinnbringende argumente in dieser doch
sehr hitzigen debatte vielen herzlichen
dank
verena hubert für die spd-fraktion wo
sie stellvertretende vorsitzende ist
verweist auf die entlassungs pakete die
die koalition beziehungsweise
bundesregierung schon vorgelegt habe
unter anderem heute frühen abend das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 im
bundestag abschließend auf dem programm
und jetzt kein gottschalk für die hfg
ist wirklich wirksamer als die ampel
treten sie zurück dass wir schon mal
general rezept für dieses land zweitens
liebe kollegen von der cdu/csu leiden
sie eigentlich ein kollektive amnesie
die pendlerpauschalen sie seit 2004
nicht angefasst da gab es sogar noch
sozial demokratische beteiligung janne
tarif auf rädern angeboten sachargument
die co2 abgabe ist von ihnen mitgetragen
worden der hals über kopf ausstieg aus
der atomkraft von ihrer schuldenkönigin
und kanzlerin merkel und euro-rettung
und schulden renten und negativ cent auf
dem konto verehrte kollegin der cdu csu
das ist ja geradezu schlägt dem fass den
boden aus versichert treiben kollege
meister ich schätze sie aber wie können
sie so eine rede halten nach 16 jahren
regierungskoalition meine damen und
herren
leider im vorliegenden antrag kommen wir
zu den sachargumenten wird nicht einer
ihrer sieben punkte begründet man hat ja
wohl auf die schnelle tatsächlich den
populismus machen wollen oder vielleicht
weil sie in der kirche und wollen jetzt
buße tun die einzige partei die seit 5
hier im hause etwas gegen inflation
euro-rettung und negativzins bringt und
hat ist die fdp fraktion meine damen und
herren das gehört entweder von fehler
den lkw gesagt sie sind die lösung nicht
alles was in diesem antrag zur lesung
ist kritisieren wir seit jahren und ich
darf mit erlaubnis der präsidentin aus
der welt vom 30 august 20 21 zitieren
das sozialpolitische erbe der kanzlerin
sind vor allem schulden also herr
meister auch der satz eben mit den 300
milliarden da sollten sie in sack und
asche gehen
noch interessanter wird es allerdings
sind uns die gegenwärtige ezb-politik
einmal anschauen denn die ist nicht nur
angemessen sie ist aus unserer sicht und
auch da prozessieren wir frau kollegin
weil wir sie für rechtswidrig und mit
der verfassung nicht vereinbar halten
bei der damen und herren und auch hier
in gedanken zu ende zu bringen einmal
die aktuelle geldpolitik der ezb mit
whatever it takes von herrn draghi bord
rwe tanks der satz heißt inflation dem
hier und unsere sparen und sparer die
rentner und die ärmeren und mittleren
einkommen in deutschland jetzt bezahlen
das ist das erbe von herrn draghi
gleichzeitig meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
und die kalte progression die wir hier
mit dem tarif auf rädern und wir haben
ihn wieder bei gestellt und herr lindner
auch da haben sie haben die sie ihre
partei hat das noch im wahlprogramm
stehen haben wir hier mehrmals
eingebracht das erste mal am 13 februar
2009 10 und als wir am 17 februar 22 im
hohen hause zum thema debattiert über
unseren antrag wurde auch einst mehr als
deutlich die er linkeren fraktion bei
uns hier im hause den gefällt es sogar
dass für die kalte progression haben sie
würden lieber und das ist eben in ihrer
rede auch klargeworden neue um
verteilungsmechanismen erfinden um das
geld nach ihrem gutdünken und das ist
das gefährliche hin zu verteilen und wer
den kollegen schrodi in dieser debatte
aufmerksam zugehört hat wird bemerkt
haben dass er große lust hat gerade für
höhere einkommen die kalte progression
oder zum besseren teil gar nicht
abzuschaffen meine damen heimliche
steuererhöhungen durch die kalte
progression küche das ist ihr rezept
aber es trifft alle menschen in diesem
land und grad kalte progression das ist
wissenschaftlich belegt trifft die
anderen menschen meine damen und herren
und genau wegen solchen politischen
handelns oder vielmehr nicht handelns
gibt es länder auf der welt wie
beispielsweise die schweiz die die
automatische beseitigung der kalten
progression in ihre verfassung
geschrieben haben und meine kollegen von
der cdu da ist wäre ein argument unseren
tarif auf rädern doch nur endlich
zuzustimmen die schweiz als musterland
der demokratie das mit gutem grunde
wahrscheinlich in ihrer verfassung
hineinschreibt und sagen wir mal den
doch etwas ausgaben freudigen händen der
politik entzieht dann ist das ein guter
grund und herr kollege butting in der
schweiz dem land das eben als vorbild
sieht da antwortet auf die frage jetzt
vom der letzten debatte kommen sie mit
ins boot und stimmen sie unserem antrag
den tarif auf rädern bitte zu und ich
habe im übrigen auch nicht vernommen
dass in der schweiz debattiert wird die
verfassung zu ändern weil dieser
automatismus so gefährlich wäre weil es
ja das königsrecht des haushaltes ist
und ein kurzes argument noch in richtung
fdp ich habe es eben schon erwähnt es
wäre ihre verantwortung gewesen herr
lindner diese krabbelgruppe und
experimentier gruppe bestehend aus
grünen und spd wieder auf den
finanzpolitischen richtigen pfad zu
bringen schauen sie in ihr wahlprogramm
dort steht der tarif auf rädern
entlasten sie die menschen wirklich und
hören sie auf mit diesen link
sozialistischen experimenten meine damen
und herren und liebe wählerinnen und
wähler in nrw wählt sie die partei die
für sie da ist und das jahr stehe und
keine andere
bei gottschalk finanzpolitischer
sprecher der fdp fraktion und ihm wird
jetzt folgen einer finanzpolitische
sprecherin und zwar katharina weg aus
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und bei diesem so wichtigen
thema für uns alle in diesem land auf
liebe bürgerinnen und bürgern
immer aber ansonsten ist das auch
manchmal einen debatten raum einfach
hier um uns über unsere gesetzesvorhaben
auszutauschen habe das geht uns wirklich
alle an und danke auch an die cdu csu
fraktion dass sie das bei diesen
prominenten dieser prominenten uhrzeit
aufgesetzt haben
73 prozent
eine relativ abstrakt wirkende zahl
und diese zahl materialisiert sich
gerade bei uns allen im alltag ich weiß
nicht ob sie sich erinnern an die
tagesthemen das bild wo alina gut das
brötchen da hatte wo einzelne produkte
sogar bei über 40 prozent erhöht waren
gurken tomaten wie teuer das alles
geworden ist im alltag der menschen ist
diese installation unfassbar real
unfassbar hoch gestern habe ich mit
einigen jungen eltern gesprochen die in
urlaub fahren wollen endlich nach der
korona krise und das häuschen oder den
zeltplatz sogar an der ostsee sich gar
nicht leisten können wir haben schon
super lange und das ist auch ein
essenzieller teil des punktes dem ich
heute machen möchte strukturelle
probleme das sieht man beispielsweise
auch im immobilien und im wohnbereich
diese preise sind schon lange hoch und
in den mails energiebereich das haben
wir gerade eben besprochen ist das thema
wirklich groß wir haben es jetzt an den
zapfsäulen und wir haben auch im
nächsten jahr spätestens auch unseren
heizkostenrechnung und das ist wichtig
wir haben akut wirkliche probleme aber
wir müssen auch strukturell an die
probleme angehen und da greift ihre
problemanalyse der reinen geldpolitik
einfach zu kurz
ja
die zentralbank sollte agieren das ist
aber ihre rechtlich verbriefte und
richtige unabhängigkeit die zentralbank
ist für preisstabilität da
und ich wundere mich manchmal weil sich
ja so als wirtschaftspartei darstellt
kreisel entstehen doch durch angebot und
nachfrage
das wissen wir und wir haben wirklich
große probleme die jetzt auch noch als
externe schocks hinzukommen wir haben
beispielsweise der ukraine und in
russland krieg den sie überhaupt nicht
erwähnen und wir haben damit
zusammenhängende energieprobleme
ernährungsprobleme und diese
energieprobleme die sind noch
strukturell ich weiß nicht in welchem
wirtschaftsbereichs die unterwegs sind
aber wir waren zu 55 prozent abhängig
von einem einzigen lieferanten
ich bin ja finanzpolitikerin wenn ich
ein paar gestalten würde wohl ein titel
55 prozent ausmachen würde der würde
überhaupt nicht geklappt weil das
risikoprofil so schlecht ist und das
haben sie uns leider der tibeter
wir müssen jetzt und ich bin dieser
regierung in ihrer gänze sehr dankbar
dass sie diese kluge wirtschafts und
energiepolitik mitträgt mit aller kraft
diversifizieren dient das angebot bei
der energie wir haben es geschafft von
55 prozent auf 35 prozent abhängigkeit
vom gas schon runter zu kommen in einer
kraftanstrengung und sie haben es in
ihren 16 jahren hinbekommen die
abhängigkeit um ein drittel zu erhöhen
das ist doch keine kluge
wirtschaftspolitik und wir legen hier in
den ersten monaten schon eine wirklich
kluge energie und wirtschaftspolitik
vorgestanden und
das thema ernährung hängt auch sehr
stark an lieferketten aber auch an
energie der größte treiber sind nicht
irgendwelche flächen prozente sondern
der größte treiber für die getreide und
innig und ernährungsweise sind gerade
die energiekosten und deswegen ist
dieses thema so wichtig und wir müssen
in der wirtschaftspolitik endlich auch
mal darüber sprechen was resilienz
eigentlich zu bedeuten hat globale
strukturen sind wichtig aber auch
regionale und lokale strukturen das
sehen wir doch jetzt so ergreifend und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir hier mit
unserer fortschritts koalition genau
diese kreislaufwirtschaft global lokal
und regional auch in europa denken und
unser zukunftsfähig aufstellen
gerade stehen vor den küsten der ukraine
große schiffe voll mit getreide die
nicht losfahren dürfen wir haben ein
riesiges lieferketten problem auch in
shanghai einen der größten
umschlagplätze dieses landes das heißt
es wichtig hier klug auszubalancieren
wie der global und regional zusammen
denken
leider hinterlassen sie uns in einigen
branchen auch dysfunktionale merkte ich
nehme noch einmal das beispiel der
energie wir haben dort leider
oligopolistische marktstruktur
alles was wir dort drehen kann im moment
ist komplett in sicher ob das überhaupt
weiter neben werden kann an die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und
auch hier wir stärken das kartell und
wir müssen wirklich ich bin wirklich für
wettbewerb ja aber für guten wettbewerb
mit guten rahmenbedingungen und das ist
das was diese ampel koalition endlich
umsetzen wird nach 16 jahren die das
nicht geschafft haben sondern und
dysfunktionale märkte hinterlassen haben
wir haben frau hubert hatte es schon
gesagt natürlich akut
die entlastungs paket sind
denkt wir haben einfach ein großes
problem dass sich menschen trage etwas
nicht leisten können da rede ich vom
kinder sofort zuschlag ja dass man sich
vielleicht auch noch mal ein kinoticket
leisten können
dann rede ich tatsächlich auch von der
energiepreis pauschale auch vom 9 euro
tiefe dass man überhaupt an die ostsee
fahren kann das bringen wir alles auf
den weg wir machen wirtschaftshilfen und
sie gehen aber auch die strukturellen
probleme an und das ist einfach
unfassbar wichtig sowohl für die
wirtschaft unseres landes für die
zukunftsfähigkeit unseres kontinents der
in eine klimaneutrale und soziale
zukunft gemeinsam gehen kann mit guten
wertschöpfungsketten und dass wir es
trotzdem schaffen gemeinsam geben die
angebots und nachfrage strukturen in
funktionierenden märkten hin zu bekommen
und somit
somit liegt die zukunft
nicht nur darin jetzt akut abzufedern
auch da aufzupassen dass wir nicht neue
inflationsspirale sie hatten sie
angesprochen ankurbeln sondern dass wir
eben tatsächlich die rahmenbedingungen
dieses einen planeten nachdem wir
zusammenleben berücksichtigen dass wir
darin gute wertschöpfungskette
entwickeln und dass wir gleichzeitig mit
denken aber dieses gleichzeitig die
balance jetzt die bürgerinnen und bürger
und die unternehmen mit großen
wirtschafts und finanz hilfen zu
unterstützen dass wir das hinbekommen
und da bin ich sehr dankbar dass auch
diese
innovative
dreier-koalition da jeweils bei ihren
herzens themen durchaus auch belastbar
ist ihr kaufen rating energie ein achter
wurde es nicht unbedingt gebäude aber
wir tun das zum wohle dieses volkes
dieser gesellschaft und europas und auf
diesen klugen weg auch mit der inflation
umzugehen freue ich mich gemeinsam in
den nächsten jahren
katharina beck finanzpolitische
sprecherin von bündnis 90/die grünen und
hier bekommen wir jetzt einen auftritt
in dieser debatte der ja selteneren
dafür ist die rednerin umso bekannter
sahra wagenknecht aus der fraktion die
linke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja die preise steigen und
steigen und sie fressen den menschen
einkommen und wohlstand weg selbst
mittelschicht familien müssen sich
einschränken und wer vorher schon mit
seinem gehalt oder seine kleinen rente
kaum über dem monat kam der ist am
verzweifeln
aber diese höchste inflation seit über
40 jahren die isny vom himmel gefallen
und die ist auch nicht nur ergebnis des
ukraine krieg sondern sie ist vor allem
ergebnis eines eklatanten
politikversagen es hier in unserem land
und ich denke wir müssen uns
geht es ihnen nicht zu denken gibt es
ihnen nicht zu denken dass der preis für
den liter diesel
nirgendwo in der eu so stark gestiegen
ist wie in deutschland bei strompreisen
sie mir schon lange spitzenreiter und
trotzdem sind sie jetzt noch mal 20 mal
so schnell gestiegen wie in frankreich
und auch bei lebensmittel bei gas ist
das tempo der preissteigerung woanders
lange nicht so hoch wie hier und dem
wirtschaftsminister fällt dazu nur ein
wir werden alle ärmer werden nein herr
habeck wenn preise steigen dann werden
durchaus nicht alle ärmer es werden auch
einige sehr viel reicher nämlich die die
steigenden preise am ende kassieren und
die gibt es allein im märz haben die
öl-konzerne hier in deutschland
zusätzliche gewinne in höhe von 1,2
milliarden euro gemacht 1,2 millionen in
einem monat und auch bei gas der seinen
doch vor allem die zwischenhändler ab
dennoch bekommen wir ja das billige
russische gas aus den langfristverträgen
das heißt wir sehen hier einige machen
schamlos reibach mit dem krieg und die
regierung schaut zu ich finde das
empörend
und warum warum steigen die
lebensmittelpreise so rasant gleich zu
beginn des krieges gab es einen heißen
tipp für reiche leute wie man jetzt
schnell sein geld vermehren kann
agrarfonds das sind fonds die auf
steigende preise für lebensmittel wetten
und mit diesem wetten die preise erst so
richtig nach oben treiben und seit
beginn des krieges hat diese zockerei so
regelrecht geburt und ich finde dass es
auch völlig unakzeptabel denn die
rechnung dafür zeit otto
normalverbraucher der supermarktkasse
und das muss man alles nicht laufen
lassen und andere europäische
regierungen lassen es auch nicht laufen
entspannen und portugal wurde anfang mai
per gesetz der gaspreis fast halbiert
und auch der strompreis wurde gesenkt in
vielen ländern gibt es mittlerweile
gesetzliche preis decke für energie nur
der deutschen regierung fehlt offenbar
das rückgrat dazu stattdessen wollen sie
jetzt offenbar durch ein öl embargo die
preise noch weiter in die höhe treiben
und die grüne außenministerin will sogar
unsere gesamten energie import aus
russland auf null drücken für immer wie
sie stolz verkündet hat und auch die
union unterstützt doch das öl embargo
und teilweise sogar noch weiter gehende
forderungen und inszenieren sie sich
hier als vertreter des kleinen mannes
wie verlogen ist das denn
merkens nicht
merken sie nicht dass die ganze
sanktionspolitik uns vielmehr als putin
schadet ihnen gar nicht auf dass der
euro seit februar immer mehr an wert
verliert während der rubel inzwischen
sogar über steht alles zu beginn des
krieges da muss man doch mal darüber
nachdenken warum das so ist russland
kann seine energie eben auch woanders
verkaufen denn der größte teil der welt
beteiligt sich eben nicht an ihren
sanktionen aber bei uns gehen bei
explodierenden energiekosten
wortwörtlich die lichter aus und
deutschland wird wichtige teile ihrer
seiner in seiner industrie verlieren
wenn sich der kurs von vw überhaupt
durchsetzt und deswegen muss man ganz
klar sagen herr bundeskanzler stellen
sie ihre ampel bei der grünen energie
preistreiberei endlich auf rot und
machen sie politik für die menschen hier
im land
sahra wagenknecht
linksfraktion mit ihrer sicht auf die
dinge
insbesondere was die preissteigerungen
im energiesektor angeht der nächste
redner ist markus herbrand und der ist
stellt finanzpolitischer sprecher der
fdp fraktion
zurück in deutschland sowie im gesamten
euroraum ist die inflation im laufe des
vergangenen jahres vor allem als folge
der korona krise sprunghaft angestiegen
übrigens sehr viel stärker als auch von
vielen ökonomen erwartet das liegt nicht
zuletzt daran dass weltweite
lieferketten gestört sind daneben wirken
sie steigt transport und auch
produktionskosten belastend aus und
jetzt kommt selbstverständlich auch noch
der krieg zusätzlich hinzu keine frage
es handelt sich um ein wirklich
wichtiges thema die antwort der
antragstellenden fraktionen ist jedoch
unseriös zum einen deshalb weil sie
alles das was schon geschehen ist bzw
augen wirklich im parlament schon
verfahren ist unterschlagen und zum
anderen deshalb weil sie uns natürlich
auch verschweigen wie sie denn noch mehr
entlastungen eigentlich finanzieren
wolle
soweit zum grundsätzlichen gerne drei
punkte konkret erstens suggeriert der
antrag dass die stars der staat die
inflation quasi im alleingang beheben
kann sie gehen in ihrem antrag
fahrlässig unsauber mit der trennung
zwischen geld und fiskalpolitik um einen
grundpfeiler unserer wirtschaftsordnung
das wissen sie auch besser die ursachen
von inflation kann nämlich nur die
geldpolitik also die zentralbank will
kämpfen deswegen ist geldwertstabilität
im aufgaben buch der ezb auch das
oberste ziel deswegen ist es maximal
populistisch so zu tun als könnte die
fiskalpolitik also der staat die
inflation voll beheben sie kann aber wie
der finanzminister ist immer sagt die
folgen abfedern und zweitens die
ampelkoalition hat innerhalb weniger
monate so massive entlastungen auf den
weg gebracht wie vermutlich noch niemals
zuvor in so kurzer zeit es handelt sich
sowohl um einmalige maßnahmen als auch
um dauerhaft wirkende maßnahmen und ich
muss sie mal auf listen das corona
steuer hilfe gesetz vier schaffen wir
mit dem kroner steuer hilfe gesetz vier
schaffen wir elf milliarden euro
entlastung mit einem
steuerentlastungsgesetz einschließlich
kinderbonus und energiepreis pauschale
werden den bürgerinnen und bürgern auf
die dauer der gesamten legislaturperiode
30 millionen milliarden euro
zurückgegeben mit der abschaffung der
eeg umlage werden unternehmen sowie
bürgerinnen und bürger alleine in diesem
jahr mit 6,6 milliarden euro entlastet
zudem sammeln wir mit der temporären
absenkung der energie steuer auf
kraftstoffe nochmal 3,15 milliarden
obendrauf und da stellt meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die eeg-umlage
bieber ansonsten konstant setzt die
ampel damit für den rest der
legislaturperiode rund 67 milliarden
euro für nachhaltiges soziale
zukunftsweisende entlassen das maßnahmen
um die natürlich die inflation abfedern
liebe kollegen und kolleginnen die
inflation
wird ungerecht den kosten für energie
und lebensmittel belasten schwächere
haushalte mehr als finanzstärke die
finanzstärkeren teile unserer
gesellschaft deswegen adressieren wir
unsere maßnahmenpakete auch in erster
linie an diejenigen die diese
inflationären wirkungen härter treffen
familien bezieher von transferleistungen
aber auch eben diejenigen die eigenes
erwerbseinkommen erzielen und sich am
unteren sowie in der mitte des der
einkommensskala befinden wir halten das
für den richtigen weg und dritter punkt
vor allem in bezug auf die punkte 6 und
7 ihres forderungskataloges liebe
kollegen und kollegen der cdu csu sind
zweifel angebracht ob anträge bei ihnen
eigentlich nochmal gegengelesen werden
unter punkt 7 fordern sie und ich
zitiere im rahmen der zur verfügung
stehenden haushaltsmittel die
grundgesetzliche schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten das muss man erst mal wirken
lassen in meinen augen im rahmen der zur
verfügung stehenden haushaltsmittel die
grundgesetzliche schuldenbremse
einzuhalten der tiefpunkt ist aber der
punkt 6 wir fordern sie allen ernstes
für alle eu vorhaben ein moratorium von
zwei jahren das ist absurd das ergebnis
einer solchen forderung macht meines
erachtens die eu gestaltungs unfähig
keine einheitlichen sanktionen keine
einheitlichen maßnahmen mehr zur
energiesicherheit keine weiteren
fortschritte in der außen- sicherheits-
finanzpolitik oder auf sonstigen
politikfelder es wäre ein faktischer
stillstand für die gesamte europäische
union es erscheint geradezu protest dass
ausgerechnet die cdu csu die eigene
kommissionspräsidentin entmachten und
die eu zur unfähigkeit blockieren will
dass sie sich offenbar nicht zu schade
sind diese forderungen auch gegen die eu
hier einzubringen zeigt dass sie auch
mal jetzt auch dem plenum an der
richtigen stelle neben der afg sitzen
ich hoffe sehr dass punkt ein versehen
war das zeigt aber auch das beste an
ihrem antrag ist die überschrift
erzielte
markus herbrand der finanzpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion da doch noch
mit recht harschen worten am ende seines
redebeitrags hier zu einem antrag der
unionsfraktion mit vorschlägen wie die
inflation bekämpft werden soll ließ die
gegenrede möglichkeit ganz sparen
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unions-fraktion nationen ist stille
enteignungen sie frisst ersparnisse auf
die bürgerinnen und bürger bekommen
weniger für ihr geld das spüren sie im
supermarkt an der tankstelle in der
bäckerei
inflation ist zutiefst unsozial sie
trifft kleinere und mittlere einkommen
die hart arbeitende mitte im land
besonders hart
angesichts einer rekord inflation hat
us-präsident beiden inflation zu dem
top-thema der amerikanischen politik
gemacht top priority von dieser
regierung von diesem bundeskanzler hören
sie mir dazu nichts wieder hier im
deutschen bundestag noch am sonntagabend
das thema das alle bürgerinnen und
bürger beschäftigt das geht nicht davon
weg
die bundesregierung diese koalition
dieses thema geht nicht davon weg dass
sie nicht darüber reden oder nicht
darüber reden wollen und übrigens weil
sie immer die 16 jahre ansprechen es gab
in den 16 jahren zuvor nicht einmal die
hohe inflation die wir gerade haben
handeln sie endlich bei dem thema das
die bürger retten am meisten beschäftigt
bei beiden gespannt möchten sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der afc zu lassen
wir haben einen sieben punkte plan gegen
preissteigerungen vorgelegt und haben
dabei drei ansätze das eine ist
kurzfristig die entlastung vor allem
beim preistreiber energie und
steuerentlastungen energie preise sind
schon angesprochen worden und ja sie tun
was ohne zweifel wir haben darüber ja
auch letzte woche schon gesprochen es
ist nur zu wenig zu spät und zu
bürokratisch das ist das problem und
deswegen schlagen wir einmal mehr vor
die steuern auf die energie zu senken
das entlastet in der breite und in der
tiefe die bürgerinnen und bürger die es
betrifft und wenn sie dann schon die 300
euro pauschale machen wenn sie an der
stelle richtigerweise entlasten dann
bitte entlasten sie auch rentnerinnen
und rentner die studenten die minijobber
auch die leichen unter der hohen
inflation und die bekommen von ihrem
paket gar nichts ab und auch das muss
dann hier thematisiert werden und wenn
es dann heißt es müsste ich auch
finanziert werden herr herbrand dass sie
an dem tag an dem der finanzminister
rekord steuereinnahmen verkünden wird
bei der finanzschätzung an dem tag wo
klar wird dass ein prozent inflation
etwa 10 milliarden mehreinnahmen für den
staat bedeutet wir so tun als wäre das
geld dafür nicht da es geht darum den
bürgerinnen und bürgern vor allem bei
den energiepreisen das zurückzugeben was
sie aufgrund der höheren preise gerade
mehr auch bei den steuern zahlen darum
geht so dafür ist das geld ohne zweifel
auch dass
der zweite ansatz ist die preise sind
hoch auch weil die nachfrage höher ist
als das angebot deswegen geht es darum
das angebot zu erweitern und das ist
übrigens eine änderung in der
wirtschaftspolitik der letzten zehn
jahre notwendig geworden eben durch die
neue lage wo es jetzt darum geht auch
stärker wieder wachstum des angebots
fördernde reform in den blick zu nehmen
was produktivität angeht bürokratieabbau
im übrigen europäisch wie deutsch können
dazu es gab schon gesagt worden das
angebot wird aber auch erweitert durch
freien handeln
und wir haben das wir schon öfter
angesprochen aber ich will es noch
einmal tun weil das thema wirklich
grundsätzlich und wichtig ist wenn wir
mit einem start wie kanada
einen freihandel treiben können mit wem
denn dann wir können nicht nach katar
fliegen um gas zu kaufen aber die
beziehung zu kanada problematisieren
wissen sie was der entscheidende teil
konnten auch denn seine zeit konnten
auch das sagt nicht entspannen das sagt
winfried kretschmann der
ministerpräsident von baden württemberg
wenn er das so sieht liebe grüne sollten
auch sie endlich ist möglich machen dass
wir zehnter hier im deutschen bundestag
endlich ratifizieren können
und neben der kurzfristige entlastung
und der erweiterung des angebotes geht
es auch ja in unseren siebten punkt
darum die schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten ab dem nächsten jahr und
beim stabilitätspakt in der europäischen
union auch zurückzukehren zu den gründen
seiner zeit wie dieser mit dieser
inflation verschuldungsgrad präsident in
gedanken bin ich noch zu ende führen
verschuldung vor allem mit der ezb
politik verbunden eben auch zu höherer
inflation führt und der finanzminister
hat gesagt er will sich in dieser frage
der schuldenbremse so das zitat am
haushalt 2023 messen lassen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das kann ich
ihnen zu sagen wir werden ihnen daran
messen dass diese schuldenbremse im
nächsten jahr wie zugesagt wieder
eingehalten wird
zwischen ernst zu lassen möchten und von
herrn ernst
danke ersparen dass sie die frage zu
lassen wir reden über die
preissteigerungen jetzt ist ihnen sicher
genauso bekannt wie wir das ein
wesentlicher treiber der preise zurzeit
die energiepreise sind
und sie haben auch richtigerweise
festgestellt ist eine frage von angebot
und nachfrage
jetzt habe ich noch nicht wahrgenommen
von ihrer fraktion dass sie irgendetwas
getan hätten um energiebereich die
nachfrage zu erhöhen die nachfrage
wieder leicht zu erhöhen die man darüber
nachdenken ob die sanktionen die wir
verhängen insbesondere im energiebereich
er uns schaden die preise treiben
produktnutzen sind sie mit mir die
auffassung unabhängig davon ob jetzt
dass der krieg verbrecherisches brauchen
das ist unbestritten aber ist es an der
stelle nicht so dass wenn wir jetzt
tatsächlich dazu beitragen würden für
ferne zeit jedenfalls weiter öl und gas
zu beziehen das dass die nachfrage eher
erhöhen würde und damit auch die preise
auch sinken
entschuldigung gehört das angebot
erhöhen und damit die preise auch senden
würden werde dies wäre das für sie eine
möglichkeit darüber nachzudenken dass
die stadt solche anträge einzubringen
die teilweise nicht zielführend sind
über ganz normale ökonomische vorgänger
die wir selbst die wir selbst momentan
ins gegenteil verkehren von der wirkung
her ob er da nicht eine entlastung für
die bürgerinnen und bürger hinkriegen
wird also ganz konkret gefragt sind sie
der auffassung dass über der steigerung
des angebots bei gas und öl gegenwärtig
ist nur die russen dazu in der lage dies
zu tun auch unsere preise stabilisieren
können also herr ernst das ist kann
nicht sein richtiger weise an der stelle
gerade der einwurf zuerst einmal beim
gas gibt es bis jetzt überhaupt noch gar
keine einschränkung des angebotes um das
auch mal klar zu sagen und wir finden es
im übrigen richtig und tragen das auch
ausdrücklich politisch mit so schwer
dass in der abwägung ist dass wir
schnellst möglich aber eben schrittweise
so wie es auch verantwortbar ist aus der
abhängigkeit von russischer energie
rauskommen und gleichzeitig gleichzeitig
aber eben das auch entsprechende folgen
im land haben sie ideologie ansprechen
die ideologie ist ja meistens dann wenn
man nicht bereit ist wenn die welt sich
ändert die eigene position zu verändern
sie die linkspartei sollte endlich
einmal das verhältnis zu russland
angesichts dessen was wir gerade jeden
tag sehen und vor allem angesichts
dessen was das ukrainische volk jeden
tag erleiden muss tod verbrechen
vergewaltigung sie sollten endlich ihr
verhältnis zu russland klären bevor sich
nicht nur fragen stellen fest
ist die fenster immer noch die fünfte
kolonne moskaus bei allem was sie tun
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die rekord inflation ist
das thema für die bürgerinnen und bürger
und es ist übrigens einmal mehr die
unionsfraktion die die themen die die
bürgerinnen und bürger beschäftigt in
dieser sitzungswoche zum thema macht wir
erwarten
wir erwarten dass die bundesregierung
das thema inflation um preissteigerungen
auch zu ihrem thema macht dazu haben wir
einen sieben punkte plan vorgelegt
handeln sie endlich sie tun es nicht für
uns sie tun für die bürgerinnen und
bürger
jetzt sparen wir das stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion mit
einem kleinen intermezzo mit klaus ernst
aus der linksfraktion und vor mir noch
mal der hinweis gegen 17 uhr 30 minimal
wird es sich wahrscheinlich verspäten
heute im bundestag die
steuerentlastungsgesetzes 20
sie ist das absolut wichtigste thema
gerade für menschen in meiner generation
in meiner altersgruppe viele von meinen
studienkollegen freundin wissen gar
nicht mehr wie sie ihr leben finanzieren
sollen die immobilienpreise sind ins
unermessliche gestiegen hat steigen die
lebensmittelpreise die energiepreise
steigen diese inflation ist
unverantwortlich unverantwortlich den
bürgern in unserem land gegenüber aber
sie haben jetzt die aufmerksamkeit
richtung beiden gerichtet haben gesagt
er hat das zur top priorität gemacht ich
möchte ihre aufmerksamkeit male auf ein
land richten das weniger weit weg ist
das ist ein land das nicht in der eu ist
nicht in der eurozone ist dafür
vernünftige politik und direkte
demokratie hat das ist die schweiz und
während wir in deutschland mit einer
inflation von siebeneinhalb prozent
kämpfen hat die schweiz eine inflation
von lediglich zweieinhalb prozent und
das bedeutet irgendwas ist ja wohl in
der europäischen union schief gelaufen
und in europäischen union ist schief
gelaufen dass die ezb geld gedruckt hat
ohne ende diese inflation sie fällt doch
nicht vom himmel sondern sie ist das
ergebnis einer stetigen
geldmengenausweitung und wenn sie die
quantität die gleichung kennen die man
dem grundstudium in der volkswirtschaft
lernen dann wissen sie geldmenge ist
gleich preisniveau wenn sie also die
geldmenge ausweiten steigt auch das
preisniveau und das haben wir über jahre
gesehen bei den immobilienpreisen das
sehen wir jetzt bei der energie bei den
lebensmittelpreisen bei allen möglichen
märkten und da frage ich sie da frage
ich sie herr sparen sie sind doch
mitglied sie sind mitglied des letzten
kabinetts gewesen das kabinett merkel
dass auf eu ebene von allein produziert
hat dass auf eu-ebene eine christine
lagarde produziert hat als chefin der
ezb christine lagarde hat angela merkel
als persönliche freundin bezeichnet was
kollegin des weiteren besitzt einen
redebeitrag aus ich stelle zeit hat die
bundesregierung denn je getan hat sie je
gesagt wenn diese geldmenge haltung
waren hier geht mehr als
2005 dann werden sie weisen eine
mittragen dann wäre so intention hinaus
herr sparen möchten sie reagieren
bitteschön
frau präsidentin ich mache es nur kurz
weil viele menschen machen wir einmal
mehr das was sie hier immer machen eine
rede für facebook und youtube halten in
der sie sich wieder schaffen können und
eine mehr davon gemacht habe es einst
ist er richtig und der kollege meistert
darauf hingewiesen und wir tun es in
unserem antrag auch das im sinne der
geldwertstabilität natürlich jetzt auch
das mandat der europäischen zentralbank
gefragt ist aber in den letzten 16
jahren im übrigen in einem
gesamtwirtschaftlich anderen umfeld in
der eurozone und in einem anderen
inflationsumfeld also wir können ja
gerne über die inflation von 4 5 43 21
jahren reden und auch in einer etwas
anderen situation ich bin ja ganz
begeistert dass frau weiter so ab werk
das sie jetzt alle fans der schweiz
geworden sind in der in der afd aber
unabhängig unabhängig unabhängig davon
ist es jetzt eben eine andere phase mit
dieser hohen inflation und sie macht
neben der geldpolitik in jedem fall auch
reformen vor darum hier in deutschland
notwendig und darauf werden wir
weiterhin hinweisen
jetzt nochmal meter in einer erwiderung
auf die kurzintervention von norbert
kleinwächter aus der afg fraktion jetzt
geht's hier im normalen web oder im
regulären sagen wir mal so debatten
verlauf weiter mit michael schrodi dem
finanzpolitischen sprecher der spd
fraktion
der präsident und herren hier sparen
wenn es eines beweises gebraucht hätte
dass sie und ihre partei gerade in einer
parallelwelt leben dann ist das ihre
rede gewesen und ihr antrag sie hören
nichts zum thema inflation von dieser
regierung ich gebe ihnen nur einen rat
heute 17 25 wurde dritte lesung
steuerentlastungsgesetz 16 milliarden
euro die wir auf den weg bringen um die
auswirkungen abzudämpfen da können sie
dann zu hören wenn sie schon nichts
hören sie müssen nur die ohren aufmachen
dann kriegen sie es auch mit stattdessen
legen es uns hier ein antrag vor
mischung aus alten programm setzen wenig
tauglichen vorschlägen und vor allem auf
maßnahmen die wir schon längst auf den
weg bringen es braucht schon sehr viel
augen auto suggestive kraft um diesen
antrag einen hilfreichen beitrag
zu der bekämpfung der inflation einer
preissteigerung zu nennen zunächst
einmal
die ursachen für die inflation
sind
importierte zu uns importierte ursachen
importierte inflation durch
energiepreise
importierte inflation durch lieferketten
probleme durch die pandemie und wundere
ich mich ersparen gerade nach dem
wortbeitrag jetzt im anschluss über die
falschen und auch populistischen
vorwürfe heber der ezb die vollkommen
deplatziert sind in ihrem antrag meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wichtig
sind jetzt moment schnelle gezielte
hilfen und nicht bestenfalls
mittelfristig wirksame forderungen wie
sie einem antrag haben wir können gern
über neue handelsabkommen sprechen wie
die wir jetzt konkret den menschen
helfen sollen in ihrer situation das
müssen sie mir erklären das tun sie
nämlich nicht meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die ampel regierung handelt
und er wünsche unterstützung dafür für
die maßnahmen die sie hier fordern die
wir aber längst auf den weg bringe ich
sage nur sie wollen anreize für
innovationen investitionen wir
verlängern die degressive
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten im chor ohne
steuer hilfe gesetz ich freue mich über
die unterstützung der cdu csu fraktion
sie wollen befristeter energie
steuersenkungen gerade für benzin und
diesel energie steuersenkungsgesetz
nächste woche mit ich freue mich auf die
zustimmung der cdu csu fraktion sie
wollen die gefahr einer
lohn-preis-spirale
entgegenwirken dann dürfen sie aber
nicht vor allen dingen bei den hohen
einkommen entlasten was sie wollen dem
antrag sondern dann müssen sie gezielt
diejenigen unterstützen die unter den
gestiegenen preisen tatsächlich leiden
die mittleren die kleinen einkommen
deswegen bringen wir das
steuerentlastungspaket auf dem weg mit
der erhöhung des grundfreibetrags mit
dem kinderbonus und auch mit der
energiepreis pauschale da übrigens wohl
sagen 44 millionen
erwerbstätige bekommen 300 euro das sind
übrigens auch die minijobber mitarbeit
und dar davon dass hier nichts davon
hören
es sind insgesamt 30 milliarden euro
die wir auf den weg bringen und das sind
maßnahmen dabei die gerade auch dazu
beitragen dass wir mittleren kleinere
einkommen entlasten die da entsprechend
betroffen sind verräterisch ist da
einsatz in ihrem antrag der sagt ja ja
das tut er ja was kleine mittlere
einkommen das hat dabei aber ihr macht
es nicht in der breite was sie beim
einen ist wir machen es nicht ganz oben
und das ist auch richtig so weil wir an
der stelle ganz genau und gezielt voran
setzen müssen wo gerade die probleme
sind und das ist genau in der breite
nämlich bis hin in die mitte der
gesellschaft und da macht man was dass
sie alle ihre forderungen dann alle
unter finanzierungsvorbehalt am anfang
stellen kann ich sagen ist geschenk für
eine oppositionspartei die muss es nicht
das ende aber dann steht das dann auch
die schuldenbremse eingehalten werden
sollen sozusagen ist alles finanzieren
das geht so nicht so geht nicht seriöse
finanzpolitik an der stelle herr
spannendes wissen sie auch ganz genau es
wirkte alles
das wirkt in ihrem antrag alles sehr
bemüht aber sie wissen ja was es
bedeutet in einem zeugnis entschied
hatte sich bemüht ich will es keine
noten vergeben zu diesem antrag aber
hilfreich ist der wahrlich für ihre
überschrift nicht ein schutzschirm
wollen sie spannen ihr antrag ist er ein
fallschirm ohne schirm deshalb legen wir
den antrag ab
michael show die der finanzpolitischen
sprecher der spd fraktion zum antrag der
hier gerade diskutiert wird aus der
unionsfraktion zur bekämpfung der
preissteigerung da schlägt die union
eine ganze reihe von maßnahmen vor die
einschätzung dazu von michael schrodi
haben wir gehört jetzt haben die
forscher aus der eifel die fraktion
antrages gemeinsam haben sie sind in
großen teilen gut im anfertigen von
plagiaten denn nichts anderes ist ihr
antrag eine kopie mehrerer unserer
eigenen anträge aus den letzten wochen
und monaten
nehmen wir zum beispiel die abschaffung
der eeg-umlage und die umsatzsteuer
absenkung auch für kraftstoffe sowie den
verzicht auf die geplante 4 prozent
regelung bei dem stilllegungsflächen all
das habe ich beziehungsweise meine
fraktion in den letzten wochen und
monaten gefordert und all dies wurde
durch ihre fraktion konsequent abgelehnt
heute schreien sie hier herum und
versuchen damit zu kaschieren dass sie
für die meisten zuständig ja selbst
verantwortlich sind sie haben doch die
letzten 16 jahre regiert da kann ich nur
eins sagen großes kino alle cdu
aber zurück zum antrag die kombination
aus hoher inflation einer einbrechenden
konjunktur und explodierenden rohstoff-
und energiepreise bei gleichzeitiger
störung der globalen warenketten ist
eine toxische mischung neben den folgen
der kroner maßnahmen um den gewachsenen
geldpolitischen konflikten und einer
seit knapp zehn jahren andauern und
katastrophalen geldpolitik der ezb ist
die inflation bereits im april diesen
jahres auf 7,4 prozent gestiegen
trotzdem verzögert die ezb die zinswende
weil die eu dieses phänomen nicht
überleben würde ein anstieg der zinsen
würde in den südlichen ländern europas
doch zusammen doch noch zum
zusammenbruch führen also opfern viel
lieber die ersparnisse der deutschen
bevölkerung und schauen einer immer
schneller werden und verarmung der
mittelschicht zu
denn wären sie früher eine familie des
gutbürgerlichen mittelstandes noch ein
eigenheim bauen konnte ist es heute für
die st selbe familie kaum noch möglich
die monatliche miete zu bezahlen das
auto zu tanken oder im supermarkt den
einkaufswagen voll zu bekommen minister
hahn beck wenn sie den 3000 mitarbeitern
der öl raffinerie in schwedt sagen dass
sie sie nicht vergangen dann stimmt das
nicht mal ansatzweise sie vergangener
nicht nur die leute dort sondern eine
gesamte nation
haben sie denn nicht im gleichen zug
angedeutet dass es durchaus zu engpässen
in der kraftstoffversorgung in mittel
und ostdeutschland kommen kann meine
damen und herren durch die von der links
grünen regierung erzeugten grünen
inflation ist es wahrscheinlich dass wir
bald drei euro mehr für den liter
kraftstoff bezahlen werden müssen aber
das ist ja auch ihr erklärtes ziel weg
vom auto hin zum lastenfahrrad liebe
kollegen der cdu statt unsere anträge
abzuschreiben stimmen sie ihnen doch
lieber gleich zu damit hätten wir die
bürger in unserem land bereits vor
monaten spürbar entlasten können vielen
dank
[Applaus]
der kollege dieter janitschek hat das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen und die
der janacek ist wirtschaftspolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin ist es gut
dass wir heute über dieses thema
inflation sprechen das wirklich viele
menschen draußen im land bewegt und auch
konkret trifft es ist aber auch wichtig
dass wir uns über die ursachen
auseinandersetzen und auch darüber reden
was wir als bundesregierung als staats
tun können und auch ehrlich sein wo wir
das nicht tun können denn wir können
nicht einen globalen angebots stock
komplett kompensieren denn der
bundesrepublik deutschland allein
die europäische zentralbank hat eine
zinswende
angekündigt oder angedeutet die
wahrscheinlich im herbst kommen wird das
ist auch nicht die aufgabe des
parlaments darüber zu entscheiden ob
eine zinswende geboten ist allerdings
muss man auch sagen wir leben nun mal
einen externen angebotsschock sehr stark
getrieben durch öl und gas durch die
preise bei den rohstoffen bei
lebensmitteln und da stellt sich die
frage inwiefern geld politik
gegensteuern kann ein stückweit
sicherlich aber auf der anderen seite
müssen wir natürlich auf die wirtschaft
am laufen halten also ich wünschte dort
auch glückliche entscheidungen
wir sehen dass wir in große abhängigkeit
sind constanze stelzenmüller hat das mal
analystin vor kurzem gesagt wir haben
militär technisch an die usa
ausgeliefert wohlstand technisch an
china und energiepolitik an russland
ganz so klar wenn ich's nicht benennen
aber wir sind abhängig und wir sehen
heute die folgen das echo von krisen
vergangener zeiten und wir sehen dass
insbesondere jetzt beim thema energie
dass wir einfach eine explosion von
preisen sehen die wir nur auf dauer
abfedern können indem wir entschlossen
investieren in erneuerbare energien
energieeffizienz und
ich nenne ich mal ein ganz konkretes
beispiel ich war letzte woche mit einer
wirtschaftsdelegation in irland
und habe dort ein neues wort gelernt die
wind reserve irland hat fünf gigawatt
bedarf kapazität von wind aber 70
megawatt offshore an möglichkeiten dh da
ist produktion als export zu stabilen
preisen möglich dass es heute noch nicht
geschafft dass es bei den baltischen
staates auch so dass das europa der
erneuerbaren energien ist die eine
antwort gegen die inflation das ist die
eine antwort auf die inflation gebe
investieren müssen aber natürlich wird
die kurzfristigen das will ich zu
gestehen die preise nicht lösen deshalb
hat robert habeck auch vieles getan was
ich mir nicht hätte vorstellen können
noch vor einem jahr nehme ich den
energieeinkauf zu diversifizieren so
dass wir davon ausgehen können dass
werden wir in wenigen monaten heute
haben wir schon die ersten ergebnisse
einen diversifizierten gasmarkt haben
dass wir dann auch wieder sinkende
preise sehen können sicher ist das nicht
so dass wir auch 2023 wieder eine
inflations rahmen reinkommen die
erträglicher ist als heute dass die
menschen dann darf man auch wieder
besser profitieren können was aber auch
jetzt mal in ihre richtung zu schauen
was ich nicht so gern tue wirklich eine
fatale entwicklung war in den letzten
wochen muss man ehrlicherweise sagen ist
die entwicklung in china
die zero kovac strategie von präsident
in china führt dazu dass wir massive
einbrüche der chinesischen
volkswirtschaft haben dass wir
einbrüchen lieferketten haben die uns
auch ganz konkret treffen und auch das
können wir nicht aus der bundesrepublik
deutschland beeinflussen das ist etwas
was wahrscheinlich erst nach dem
volkskongress im oktober geklärt wird
wenn china versteht dass es falsch war
eine politik zu machen die dem eigenen
volk der eigenen wirtschaft schade dass
wir das besser gemacht haben indem wir
gesagt haben wir müssen irgendwann auch
mal mit diesem virus leben und mit
unseren impfstoffen die besser sind als
die chinesischen was können wir tun zum
einen konkret entlasten das haben wir
getan aber dort wurde mehrfach
angesprochen von der schule von
katharina weg dort mitte entlasten nicht
beim suv fahrer sondern dort wo es
gebraucht wird die union hatte eine
energie preissenkung in kosten höhe von
40 milliarden euro vorgeschlagen
schreibt in den antrag dass er die
schuldenbremse einhalten will das ist
einfach nicht seriös mit verlaub das ist
keine glaubwürdige politik richtung
inflation und am ende brauchen wir die
kreativität unserer volkswirtschaft
natürlich sind hohe preise auch gerade
bei energie haben lenkungseffekte und
wir sehen gerade kreativität in den
betrieben die sich darauf einstellen wie
wir mit diesen lenkungseffekte umgehen
unsere volkswirtschaft modernisieren mit
weniger energie mit erneuerbarer energie
und mit den fähigkeiten die wir haben
auch modernität wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu
schaffen darum geht es jetzt in den
kommenden wochen entlastung und
kreativität zusammen dann schaffen wir
auch diese schwere zeit vielen dank
italienische klar dass der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen in der
debatte des bundestages zu einem antrag
der unionsfraktion mit allerlei
vorschlägen die die preissteigerungen
bekämpfen sollen koalition die ampel
koalition verweist hier in ihren
diversen beiträgen darauf dass sie in
dieser hinsicht ja bereits eine menge
macht maximilian mordhorst könnte das
unterstützen er spricht wie die fdp
freizeit die ernsthaftigkeit der
inflation die sie auch in ihrem antrag
völlig zurecht ansprechen will jetzt
wegen und der kollege herr brandt hat
das schon sehr gut gemacht mal sagen was
wir so alles tun es wurde ja schon im
einzelnen aufgezählt aber dass man auch
mal eine gesamtsumme hat wie entlasten
menschen jetzt mit mehreren paketen um
37 milliarden euro ohne dass wir das so
geplant hatten das ist ein riesen eine
riesen hilfe für die menschen in
deutschland und eine große hilfe für die
menschen die von den energiepreisen und
von der inflation belastet sind ich
glaube das gerät hier gerade ein
bisschen in den hintergrund denn auch
das ist ja immer wieder ein punkt ihrer
kritik ich kann das alles verstehen aus
der opposition mehr geht immer und dann
macht man mal so eine liste ohne dass
man dazu hingegen finanzierungsvorschlag
hat fehlen darf alles okay aber sie
tragen in dem antrag auch schon wieder
ich will ja mal eine mehr auflösen schon
wieder dicht und die rentner vor sich
her als würden wir denen nicht helfen
ich kann ihnen dringend empfehlen hier
gleich einmal sitzen zu bleiben und den
nächsten job noch mit zuzuhören denn
dort werden wir das
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetz
verändern was sie verpennt haben in den
letzten jahren eine riesen hessische
studenten in diesem land und ich kann
ihnen empfehlen auch morgen auch morgen
um 9 uhr dabei zu sein auch wieder
wunderbar spannend wir werden eine der
größten renten wir werden die größte
rentenerhöhungen der letzten 30 jahre in
deutschland beschließen das ist fast
doppelt so lang wie 16 jahre die sie
hier durchgehend in deutschland regiert
haben also zu tun als würden wir nicht
hätten nur weil in diesem konkreten
paket nicht diese konkreten pauschale
zutrifft während nur ein euro ticket
zusätzliche pauschale alles für die
rentner und studenten kommt ich glaube
das ist nicht ehrlich ich glaube da
finden sie den leuten einen bären auf
wenn sie die studenten und rentner so
vor sich hertreiben und dann
wir machen jetzt ich sag das mal ganz
ernsthaft den machen schulden und gerade
als freidemokraten muss ich auch sagen
machen wir das nicht gerne bei uns in
einer außergewöhnlichen situationen
befinden ich glaube auch das gerät
gerade so ein bisschen in den
hintergrund oder manche wollen dass
sogar relativieren die oberste priorität
hat die hilfe die wir der ukraine
leisten und da kann ich mich um das eine
oder andere wundern wir machen ein öl an
gas auch an kohle embargo nicht gerne
und schnell aber wir machen ist so
seriös dass wir den menschen helfen und
wir machen es vorrangig weil wir die
ukraine unterstützen und war das was
russland treibt nicht mehr unterstützen
wollen und ja das wird kosten haben wir
werden dafür sorgen dass das vernünftig
verteilt wird die kosten und nicht bei
den menschen die sehr wenig verdienen
oder in der mitte der gesellschaft
stehen besonders belastet wird aber auf
der anderen seite machen wir leider
schulden in deutschland wir machen
leider schulden in deutschland das ist
völlig richtig aber sie erzählen uns
immer wieder etwas und werfen es dem
finanzminister vor der schulden minister
und so weiter und so fort was machen sie
dann mit ihrem antrag sie werfen geld
mit vollen händen aus dem offenen
fenster und sagen den menschen nichts
darüber wie das in deutschland
finanziert werden soll das ist nicht
ehrlich das macht sich teilweise sogar
lustig über die menschen die belastet
werden lieber ist seriös machen mehr
geht immer kann ich gut nachvollziehen
aber wir müssen nun mal regieren in
deutschland ich glaube sie wussten mal
wie das geht wir machen uns jetzt
vernünftig und zeigen den menschen in
deutschland wo wir ihn wirklich helfen
und nicht so wie sie das vorgeschlagen
haben vielen dank
maximilian mordhorst aus der
fdp-fraktion ganz ohne skript und ohne
zettel und ihn volkert sebastian brehm
aus der unionsfraktion das geht
weiterhin um einen antrag aus eben
seiner fraktion zur bekämpfung der
inflation
der frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ich darf wieder ein zitat des früheren
bundesbank präsidenten karl otto pöhl
beginnen diese hat gesagt mit der
inflation ist es wie mit zahnpasta ist
sie erst aus der tube bekommt man sie
nur schwer wieder hinein und liebe
kolleginnen kollegen genau in dieser
situation befinden wir uns heute und es
ist 16 jahre gab es keine inflation
jetzt ist die inflation da deswegen ist
es auch allerhöchste zeit dass jetzt
gehandelt wird und zwar einerseits bei
der ezb aber
andererseits auch insbesondere bei der
bundesregierung und wenn ich bei der ezb
bin dann ist es wichtig dass die
expansive geldpolitik und die
anleihenkäufe endlich gestoppt werden
und der negative einlagezins so bald wie
möglich verschwindet weil das reduziert
altersversorgung das reduziert wohlstand
in unserem land
aber liebe kolleginnen kollegen vor
allem die bundesregierung könnte handeln
wenn sie wollte lieber kollege schrodi
zum thema seriöse finanzpolitik
finanzminister lindner plant in einer
summe von regulären haushalt
nachtragshaushalt ergänzungs haushalt
sondern vermögen von über 300 milliarden
euro schulden das ist eine belastung der
nächsten generation par excellence das
ist absoluter negativrekord eine solche
neuverschuldung gab es noch nie weder in
der deutschen einheit noch bei der krise
2008 noch in der korona krise das ist
absoluter rekord
und eigentlich wenn es nach christian
lindner geht er hat er die wichtige
debatte leider verlassen wenn es nach
christian lindner geht müsste es
neuwahlen in diesem haus geben ich darf
ihn nämlich zitieren am vom deutschen
steuerberaterkongress am 25 22 jahren
erst kürzlich in dem er gesagt habe
lieber neue wahlen als neue schulden und
daran muss er sich dann letztlich
endlich mal messen lassen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
christian lindner geht als
schuldenkönigin die geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland ein und
übrigens dass bei den höchsten
steuereinnahmen die wir haben bald eine
milliarde euro in 2025
es ist zeit die schuldenlast zu
reduzieren und zugleich spielräume zu
erarbeiten um die private hand die
bürgerinnen und bürger und die betriebe
zu entlasten das ist kein zitat von
sebastian brehm das ist ein zitat von
christian lindner und auch daran werden
wir ihn messen er tut genau das
gegenteil und die wahrheit ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die inflation
frisst sich ohne erkennbaren widerstand
der bundesregierung in die mitte der
gesellschaft und liebe kollegen deswegen
auch unser antrag das darf so nicht
bleiben wir brauchen einen schutzschirm
gegen inflation
und der schutzschirm besteht aus drei
maßnahmen die jetzt schnell umgesetzt
werden können
inflationsbremse einführen mit einer
entlastung der kleineren und mittleren
einkommen und des mittelstandes durch
abschaffung der kalten progression
wir werden ja heute nachmittag auch
darüber reden im steuerentlastungsgesetz
übrigens auch kollegin mordhorst weil
sie sagen es ist nicht finanzierbar
alleine die mehreinnahmen aus der
umsatzsteuer im ersten quartal dieses
jahres sind über 20 milliarden euro und
sie entlasten vielleicht mit 30 im klein
klein sie könnten wesentlichen mehr
entlasten mit diesem jahr wenn man
nämlich die einkommensteuer
mehreinnahmen uns alles dazu nimmt also
eine gegenfinanzierung wäre es
selbstverständlich beraten wenn sie es
wollten möchten sie elektrische frage
von herrn motors zu lassen sind
verständlich denn
in vielen dank herr kollege dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen ich wollte mich
eigentlich nicht melden aber weil sie
mich noch direkt angesprochen haben
möchte zwei punkte machen also der erste
zu ihrem inhaltlichen punkt ist ja
völlig klar wir machen ja schon
entlastungspaket die eine gewisse menge
kosten insofern brauchen sie die summe
jetzt nicht so zu verrücken das andere
ist weil sie den für
bundesfinanzminister angesprochen haben
der befindet sich gerade einmal in einem
austausch mit dem ukrainischen
außenminister auch das vielleicht zu den
prioritäten und als erklärung warum wir
heute nicht ab oder nicht mehr er war ja
eben dabei dabei ist
also zu dem thema entlastung vielleicht
liebe kollegin mordhorst sie gleichen
mit dem paket was jetzt machen nicht
einmal ganz die preissteigerung von 2021
aus also derzeit wird die inflation 2022
in keiner weise in irgendeinem gesetz
berücksichtigt sie nehmen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern das geld ab weil
nämlich sie reduzieren durch die
inflation werde das einkommen reduziert
durch die kalte progression und durch
die negativzins wird das ersparte und
die altersversorgung reduziert also sie
nehmen doppelt den bürgerinnen und
bürger ab es wird zeit dass sie unserem
antrag zustimmen die kalte progression
die entlastung vorziehen und nicht erst
wie angekündigt vielleicht ein bisschen
im oktober oder november oder so weil
bis dahin sind die steuer wesentlich
höher und die inflation ist bei weitem
nicht ausgeglichen und kommt bei weitem
insbesondere bei den kleinen und
mittleren einkommen in deutschland nicht
an liebe kolleginnen kollegen
die inflation ist in der breite der
gesellschaft angekommen aber wir werden
es heute nachmittag auch diskutieren die
breite der gesellschaft wird nicht
entlastet die studenten nicht die
senioren nicht die familie nicht also
handeln sie jetzt und stimmen sie
unserem antrag zu
da ist sebastian brehm möglicherweise
ein wenig zu optimistisch nächster
redner und den drittletzter redner in
dieser debatte zum unionsantrag zur
bekämpfung der preissteigerungen der
inflation ist paar samawi aus der spd
fraktion
frau präsidentin die web kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren wir sind
zweifelsohne in einem angespannten
wirtschaftlichen umfeld in einem großen
volkswirtschaftlichen stresstest der
viele menschen umtreibt und bei dem das
thema inflation natürlich eine große
rolle spielt wir haben es in vielen
reden heute gehört im märz hatten wir 39
5 prozent höhere energiepreise und 62
prozent höhere nahrungsmittelpreise
als ein jahr zuvor wie immer agieren wir
nicht auf einer insel sondern genau
wegen dieser entwicklung werden aktuell
in der gesamten eurozone
viele anti inflations und viele anti
stagnation schutzschirme aufgespannt um
im bild einen schutz schon zu bleiben es
ist wichtig dass die schirme die wir
jetzt bei regen und sturm aufspannen
wetterfest und nicht mächtig sind damit
sie ihren zweck erfüllen und dabei lässt
sich sagen diese regierung diese ampel
koalition sorgt mit ihren entlastungs
paketen mit unserer auf dauer angelegten
strategie unabhängig zu werden von
fossiler energie
für stabile schutzschirme das hilft den
bürgern und bürger und unternehmen in
unserem land deutlich mehr als die
löchrigen schirme die sie von der union
hier verteilen wollen weder mut noch
angst in dieser lage angemessen sondern
entschlossenes handeln uns macht die
ampel liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wie sehr sich als union inzwischen
opposition und nicht mehr regierung sind
zeigt ihr im antrag dokumentierte umgang
mit der europäischen zentralbank und da
geht es mir gar nicht um ihre
populistischen neigungen abhandlung geht
es um ihre heizung und der zitieren wir
doch mal ihren antrag sie schreiben
wörtlich wir stehen feste unabhängigkeit
der ezb das haben wir auch heute von
einem doktor meister gehört und dann
kommt ein bemerkenswerter satz dies
setzt aber voraus dass punkt punkt punkt
daraus folgere ich die union steht nur
noch unter ganz bestimmten
voraussetzungen zur unabhängigkeit der
europäischen zentralbank
ich frage mich was ist eigentlich los
mit dieser stolzen union die 16 jahre
lang das kanzleramt gestellt hat dieser
neue todes jedenfalls beachtlich wie wir
kolleginnen und kollegen
in ihrem antrag der mehr sammelsurium
meine kollegin hubert sprach von einem
gemischtwarenladen ist als ein stimmiges
konzept sprechen sie davon dass die
ampel koalition nicht die breite der
gesellschaft entlasten würde das ist
aber ganz schöne unsinn wenn man sich
zum beispiel die aktuelle studie des emk
anschaut demzufolge finden durch unsere
entlastungs paket mit einem volumen von
mehr als 30 milliarden euro
zielgerichtete und in der breite der
gesellschaft
wirksame entlastung stadt wie folgende
beispiele zeigen
90 der belastungen aus den
energiepreisen werden bei paaren mit
zwei kindern mit einem
haushaltsnettoeinkommen von 2000 bis
2500 euro monatlich aufgefangen 77
prozent bei paaren mit zwei kindern und
einem einkommen zwischen 3600 und 5000
euro monatlich 70 prozent bei
alleinerziehenden mit zwei kindern und
einem einkommen zwischen 2000 und 2600
euro monatlich und es ließe sich
fortsetzen mit unseren maßnahmen für
menschen die sozialhilfe grundsicherung
oder alg 2 beziehen für studierende auch
für die renten da die natürlich auch
autofahren die bus und bahn fahren und
entlastet werden wie zu 46 prozent zu
den wohngeld empfängern gehören und
damit den heizkostenzuschuss bekommen
die stromrechnung bezahlen damit von der
vorzeitigen reduktion der eeg umlage auf
0 profitieren von den hier auch manche
noch eine beschäftigung eine
geringfügige beschäftigung haben die
dann natürlich auch die
energiekosten pauschale bekommen damit
zeigt sich hier in unseren entlastungs
paketen sind genau die breite und die
mitte der gesellschaft und meinetwegen
die hart arbeitende mitte die herr spahn
aufgeführt hat abgebildet der
schutzschirm der ampel koalition ist
also überaus wirksam liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
klar ist unsere akuten maßnahmen können
nur maßnahmen aufsicht sein wir arbeiten
als ampelkoalition mit einer klugen
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik
bestmöglich gegen inflation und
stagnation an niemand kann zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt in einem so
unsicheren geopolitischen umfeld präzise
vorherzusagen wie die zukunft laufen
wird nicht in bezug auf inflation nicht
in bezug auf wachstum
wir sind daher weiterhin gut beraten
auch weiterhin vorausschauend und mit
bedacht zu agieren für den moment gilt
unser vorgehen als ampel zur bekämpfung
der inflation ist stimmig der ehe
unausgereifte antrag der union hilft uns
nicht weiter wir können daher guten
gewissens zurückweisen ich danke ihnen
das hat der kollege dr klaus wiener für
die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen der sebastian
brehm hatten zitat mitgebracht haben des
bundesbankers ich habe auch noch mal
eins das hat nämlich mal einer gesagt
inflation ist die spargel wenn man ihn
sieht ist es eigentlich schon zu spät
und genauso
fühlt sich an was wir hier erleben lange
zeit wurden die gefahren der inflation
kleingeredet auch hier im parlament noch
im dezember habe ich an dieser stelle
von einer vertreterin einer der
regierungsparteien gehört dass es keinen
zusammenhang gibt zwischen der geldmenge
und der inflation und das sondereffekte
nicht überschätzt werden dürften gewagte
thesen wie wir heute wissen
die ursachen für das aktuelle hoch
schießen die ursachen für das aktuelle
hoch schießen der preise sind bekannt
lieferketten probleme in der die
verknappung und massive globaler
fiskalische impulse und weil diese
faktoren zeitlich zusammenfallen kann es
sogar sein dass die inflation
kurzfristig noch weiter steigt
allerdings dürfte entlastung spätestens
dann kommen wenn china seine häfen
wieder öffnet wäre das dann ein grund
zur entwarnung ganz sicher nicht zum
einen und das klare ja auch schon
mehrfach an weil die notenbanken in den
letzten jahren unglaublich viel geld
geschaffen haben nicht nur die ezb dabei
nur im euro raum beträgt die
überschussliquidität also das geld das
wir nicht zur finanzierung des wachstums
brauchen sechs millionen euro eine
unfassbar hohe zahl sollte dieses geld
einmal nachfragewirksam werden etwa weil
die kreditvergabe steigt dann muss die
regierung ihre inflationsprognose sich
nochmal überdenken sie hat sie ja gerade
schon verdoppelt dann würde das sicher
nicht reichen aber auch unabhängig davon
sprechen grundlegende
volkswirtschaftlicher entwicklungen
dafür dass der preisauftrieb in den
kommenden jahren sehr viel höher sein
wird als wir das in den letzten 16
jahren erlebt haben ich nenne hier nur
die im trend steigende co2 preis
stichwort green fashion die
rohstoffknappheit stichwort china auch
die neuen geopolitischen blöcke die sich
gerade formieren und die zu einer
regionalisierung des handels führen
würden und natürlich auch der euro pro
wagen gerecht wenn ich das sagen darf da
müssen sie schon ein bisschen länger
zurück gucken er ist seit 2012 schwach
war über 150 die hat es bei 105
alle diese faktoren sprechen dafür dass
der inflationsdruck im trend deutlich
über der zielmarke von zwei prozent
liegen wird hört sich harmlos an ist es
aber nicht denn schon bei einer
inflation von vier prozent jährlich
verlieren sie nach 18 jahren die hälfte
ihres vermögens bei null negativzinsen
ist das ein riesenproblem für die
altersvorsorge was ist daher zu tun
vieles wurde hier schon genannt wir
müssen die angebotsbedingungen stärken
durch neue handelsvereinbarungen liebe
grüne auch mal zeta unterschreiben durch
haushaltsdisziplin liebe fdp und durch
ein belastungsmoratorium die spd zwei
punkte liegen wir aber besonders am
herzen das ist einmal die
produktivitätsentwicklung und das andere
ist zur bekämpfung des fachkräftemangels
hohes produktivitätswachstum dämpft die
lohnstückkosten wohlgemerkt die
lohnstückkosten nicht die löhne das ist
nämlich ein unterschied und bekämpft so
wirksam die inflation und was den
fachkräftemangel an geht so musste er
durch gezielte und passgenaue
einwanderung bekämpft werden und nicht
durch einen wie auch immer gearteten
spurwechseln
der inflationsschub
der inflationsschub das will ich hier
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen hat weder
die alte noch die neue regierung zu
verschulden er ist einen angebotsschock
man kann sogar sagen ein klassischer
angebotsschock dem nahezu die ganze welt
trifft wie die regierung aber darauf
reagiert das macht einen großen
unterschied
ich kann sie deshalb nur auffordern
schließen sich unserem antrag an um die
inflation strukturell und nachhaltig zu
bekämpfen und nicht durch eine reihe von
kurzfristig wirkenden einzelmaßnahmen
vielen dank
bloß wie ne aus der unionsfraktion der
vorletzte redner in der debatte über den
antrag der unionsfraktion zur bekämpfung
der preissteigerung letzter reden also
sebastian roloff nochmal spd-fraktion
und dann geht es danach weiter mit dem
thema bafög herzlichen dank verehrte
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich bin wieder völlig begeistert sie
breitbeinig die union heute wieder
auftritt da sie die weisheit gepachtet
hätte und dann kriegen sie ist noch
nicht mal hinten antrag vorzulegen der
aus sich heraus wenigstens logisch ist
da braucht man noch nicht mal
volkswirtschaftliche kenntnisse
widerspricht sich schon in den
wesentlichen forderungen beispiel die
frage der europäischen zentralbank diese
als zentral bewerten und einerseits
fordern ezb muss unabhängig sein und das
ginge gar nicht dass da so seitens der
staaten rein regiert wird auf der einen
seite auf der anderen seite machen sie
aber politische aufforderungen die
politik zu ändern ja was gilt denn jetzt
unabhängigkeit oder vorgaben und der
antrag geht darüber hinaus
auch von völlig schäden nicht mit
rechtsradikalen sie brauchen auch nicht
dazwischen brücken
der antrag geht von völlig falschen
prämissen aus es ist in der
wirtschaftswissenschaft nichts neues
dass aktuell auslöser der aktuellen
inflation in angebotsschock ist
steigende energiepreise probleme bei den
lieferketten rohstoffengpässe das sehen
wir ja auch alles problem sind nicht die
zinsen eher im gegenteil würden wir
jetzt die zinsen erhöhen wie der antrag
das fordert würde das bisschen
wirtschaftswachstum was jetzt
hoffentlich wieder kommt er abgewürgt es
ist es kontraproduktiv wenn wir diesen
antrag heute beschließen und dann nach
vorgehen würden und das muss man doch
verstehen und das muss ja auch gesagt
werden
außerdem ist es sinnvoll bei einer
angebotsknappheit zu investieren mehr
angebote zu schaffen den preisdruck zu
entlasten und das tag da die union
haushaltskonsolidierung die heilige kuh
der schuldenbremse den schwedisch habe
ich nie verstanden selbstverständlich
müssen müssen in guten zeiten
haushalte konsolidiert werden rücklagen
geschaffen werden aber wir haben eben
keine guten zeiten wir haben
krisenzeiten unter muss investiert
werden
wenn einem das wasser bis zum hals steht
soll man den kopf nicht hängen lassen
ist ein einigermaßen bekanntes
sprichwort wendet man das auf die
schuldenbremse an es ist so als wenn man
dem ertrinken dann auch noch die hände
verbindet und er sich gar nicht mehr
wehren und agieren kann dementsprechend
konnte man mir noch nicht erklären was
das bringen soll und wir sollten von
diesem dogma in zeiten wo investitionen
erforderlich sind abstand nehmen und
alleine in dieser frau ist der antrag
nicht konsistent das ist das was ich
meine dass es keinen sinn macht die cdu
möchte entlastungen und macht konkrete
vorschläge was jetzt so macht man mit
mehreinnahmen im steuerbereich passieren
soll ja ich denke wie sollen haushalte
konsolidieren dann können wir das geld
nicht ausgeben also wohin soll die reise
gehen so gehen wir auf jeden fall nicht
den richtigen weg bei der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit möchte ich jetzt
gar nicht anfangs deutsche
leistungsbilanzüberschuss ist bei 7,5
prozent die europa lässt 6 prozent zu
aber auch da sitzt eine steigerung
gefordert sonst sind sie immer für
obergrenzen da ist jetzt mal eine
sinnvolle die ignorieren sie
wirtschaftspolitisch also ich bin
offensichtlich nicht begeistert und bin
dementsprechend froh dass die ampeln der
ganze reihe von maßnahmen einerseits
schon auf den weg gebracht oder
demnächst vorlegen wird regionale
transformations- und qualifikations
cluster klima verträge für unternehmen
eine industrie strategie
investitionsprogramme für kleine und
mittlere unternehmen stärken von
selbstständigen und die initiative des
bmw k für fachkräftesicherung zum
beispiel das sind die maßnahmen die wir
brauchen und auch beim bürokratieabbau
oder waren reformierten vergaberecht
wird es fortschritte geben zu den
entlastungs paketen ist schon viel
gesagt worden ich glaube wir brauchen
darüber hinaus weitere unterstützung der
unternehmen in der transformation da
fällt der union ja nur ein gegen den
entsprechenden fonds zu klagen das
können sie den unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern mal erklären für diese hier
sein wollen ich glaube dass wir darüber
hinaus reden sollten die
kurzarbeitsregelung auch für die
transformation zu verlängern
qualifizierungsmaßnahmen weiter zu
fördern und selbstständige
besser abzusichern schließlich freue ich
mich und bin sicher dass wir im
bundestag rief teuren vergabegesetz
brauchen ich freue mich auf die weitere
diskussion der antrag heute hilft leider
nicht weiter vielen dank
sebastian roloff war das nochmal in der
debatte zum unionsantrag zur bekämpfung
der preissteigerung der antrag wird über
wiesen im ausschuss
zuständigen ausschuss weiter diskutiert